dear friends welcome to another episode
of salaam dining today
we are visiting giftos we're going to go
inside inshallah review the place i've
got two special guests
an expert also known as a chef we're
going to go inside inshallah
and find out how good this place is and
how halal is
don't miss your chance to win a free
meal for four people just
watch the video carefully answer the
questions at the end and enjoy your free
delicious meal at gift dolls we are in
gift clothes and i have two beautiful
esteemed guests with me
brothers please embrace me
how are you gonna leave me hanging
wash your hands before you eat again
we're getting the minerals
thank you thank you thank you very much
thank you so much is it your first time
at giftos yeah never heard of it until
today
really yeah i'm literally
so he's hungry okay so probably what
we're going to do is here i'm going to
set some rules and conditions
yeah that we have at salaam dining yeah
they're gone
anyways i'll tell you later okay tell me
tell me if it's
just just a brief review of the menu is
it easy to find can you say okay you
know what
if i want to look for this this is where
i can find it i think it's well uh
and it's well laid out yeah one layer
the layout is fine
you've got the lahari dishes yeah you've
got a compliment
you know oh you've got vegetarian
section yeah that's really important
because a lot of people are
cutting down on meat company unlike
yourself rice is i'll be honest
he doesn't even believe that vegetarian
exists there's no such thing as
vegetarian and vegan
we're going to come to that so so
i know this is this yeah yeah i'm going
to get that thing you know with
chickpeas
spicy it's a spicy chickpeas and smoked
mustard no chips it's got like a samosa
in the middle yeah what is it known for
what is the place known for where is
their speciality
oh bro we're going to find out if you
find that today
if it's known for something specific or
no for order than things you're getting
that's what i want to know with it
you're going to find out buffer we're
going to find out okay okay
that's where you're going to let our
viewers know what it's known for you get
me but if you want something good get
the look
go to the hori dishes are really nice
okay
yeah so whoever has crushed that's curry
right that's curry and then
yeah and then you get some you just get
some numbers
butter chicken came from kingfish
[Applause]
lamb brain all right i know what i'm
getting what is that
lamb brain you're getting the brain yeah
yeah you can try our brains have you
ever had a brain head braids seriously
we we make it look in the culture as
well i've had brain before
you're trying it today i've had tongue
i've had the the the skull
but i've never had breakfast okay
[Laughter]
you know the meat outside the skull okay
the lining of it
yeah yeah yeah okay that's not you said
tongue though i had the sheep tongue as
well yeah okay
what's the craziest thing you've ever
tried i had sheep's stomach
yeah in my culture we stuff it with rice
that's fine and sheep tongue
that's the craziest thing i had chicken
chicken hearts
and chicken liver that's fine that's
that's not you can get that down the
bushes
what do you have what's the craziest
thing you had
chicken tikka masala
[Music]
intestines yeah yeah that's fine that's
tripe yeah
yeah that's it and uh i don't know my
mom makes chicken feet and stuff like
that as well that's that's
standard chicken chicken soup in it
that's that or my culture anyway no no
no what coach is this
which would yeah the creative thing i've
heard i had a bat
a bat a bat yeah so we're talking are we
taking an animal we're talking about the
world we have the muslim batman here
okay
okay for starter okay what i'm going to
do is
for starter i want to try this
is this the one with the chickpeas the
yogurt and tamarind sauce for the public
oh so this is this is the one yeah
yeah that's the one that's the one so
you want one puppy yeah sorry i don't
know the wrong one
that's that's good you help me okay
um okay for starter you also had you
know like a fish
you have a massage which
okay the fish
no this is starter oh okay yeah so we
don't want to is
that enough for us to try just enough is
there anything else uh get the uh
panipuri crispy puffs accompanied with
chickpeas potatoes somewhere in the soil
you're gonna make sure you eat the
starter and the mania you've got the
main comments plus it's the same
as that yeah that's the same as the
perfect character
that's that's the same that's the same
as what it's similar
is the same no this one was different
you get some water in there oh okay can
we have
this one yeah this one and the fish
please
so for the main meal what are you gonna
get brain
okay he wants the brain
okay so you want the fish brain and bro
i think this would be enough for me and
you
are you okay with this or do you want to
do something sorry chicken ass 25
i'm done with these guys i'm not serious
okay guys i'm not serious i'm done
garlic now i'm waiting now i've been
waiting for garlic
you're fine you want to eat your brain
with a rice oil
i'm ready but i'm waiting for you i can
i can order but i was waiting for you
okay do you want it with rice or bread
no may i have roti please
yes please two rotis yes
did you get that would you
do it properly like how you guys do it
for my one
and i i have one of those as well
for me with brain put some brain in
there please
but the reason i'm saying for me because
other people are thirsty around the
table
yeah and uh yes
no
okay what time did you go to the food uh
6 20 16 yeah
whoa six 17.
okay we ordered 6 17 yeah so what we're
going to do is we're going to
time when how long it takes for our food
to come
we need to monitor between you're a chef
you know the starter and the main meal
yeah okay
yep because as you know if the starter
comes and the menu takes too long to
come
you get food and you don't eat the main
meal yeah yeah so that's okay
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to talk about traveling yeah
okay
where is which country have you traveled
to
me yeah i've traveled to well okay which
country is that all right let me ask you
a question
what which country did you travel to and
what impact did it have in your life
recently i went to turkey which was a
fun experience there's not a okay
so the guys recording i actually went
with the person that's actually
recording this video today
yeah um in turkey uh yeah we had a nice
time hunter i went a few brothers
a lot a lot of brothers went to um
is a nice experience to chill with the
brothers and enjoy
um the whole great family thank you
sister thank you thank you very much
okay so what time do i starters come
quick quick quick six minutes
25. no it takes twenty
eight eight eight eight eight we all did
seventeen past twenty five
it's eight minutes for the stars just
keep that in mind yeah okay
so just as we eat we can talk as well by
the way i know if you guys know but it's
actually sunnah to eat and talk
some people think that when you're
eating it's absolutely disrespectful to
yeah yeah back home we're now let's talk
yeah yeah so hunter let's carry on
handle i've traveled quite a lot around
the world i've been there in europe uh
yeah i've been to the caribbean islands
i've been to this side of the world
you're from mauritius by the way yeah
i'm from mauritius if you have anyone
think that is bengali
uh only because we want to see
like you said like oh yeah remember when
we went to that that affected my life
that changed that literally had an
impact on me yeah i had an impact
i played it
[Laughter]
let me help you brother oh thank you
there you go
we ordered 17 parts here so 20
17 pass 23 so it's been 24 minutes is
that correct
yeah yeah i think so yeah it should be
it should be
so we took 20. i'm not very good with
numbers yeah
it did it for 17 minutes passed now it's
41 past yeah
you have 23 to 17 that's 40 plus one
21.1
you're 49 square meters 24 minutes yeah
you did much
all right you know what yeah i'm waiting
for you man
i'll eat my brain first
can i have a lemon and can we have
one water please drop on top can i tap
this yeah just go
get a big bottle of water
you guys i'm in a curry with knife and
fork
i don't i don't no no no don't say you
don't because you're having it with an
iphone 4
okay i am do you guys have encouraged
that before so already you start you
failed already
you want that traditional homely feeling
and you have a knife and fork and how
you find the food
well it's very amazing because usually i
order like
lamb karate this is very similar
okay probably so what we're gonna do is
i'm gonna with eight
we're gonna instead of ordering proper
dessert we're gonna order it but we're
gonna get a bowl
with a bit of them so we can get a gift
of the idea yeah
brother celine can we have instead of
having
dessert uh in this portion can you give
us like
a bit of everything like is it possible
like you know a bit of
the water one like the erasmus just
one one one or one piece of gulab jamun
yeah like a bit of everything so we can
get an idea because we're full we don't
want it to go to waste okay what i do
i'll give one for one
let's put this in the middle all right
i'm not i'm not really
i'm not i don't eat rasmalai i don't eat
when i don't eat kids okay guys i'm not
even kidding
i know you like kids don't eat none of
them no no rest my life
i've been force fed here bro this is
this is rasmalai is the one fan
these are just their sweet desserts that
they make this one is like a it's like
it's like a little dough
i'll need one asian dessert the green
one
i mean the carrot one the carrot orange
carrot
yeah and i like uh barfi what's that
burfi is banging bro what is it
it's barfi in it so we've had our food
we have our desserts we had our starters
i'm going to tell you guys how it works
i'm going to guide you through it while
i'm having my raspberry i'm enjoying
myself here
and i want you guys to tell me your
results
okay cool um so overall
from starter all the way down to the
dessert yeah and you can you can give
that
specific comments on any other dish that
you like yeah in general so
start all the way down to this up from
the start i like the chat uh the chat
the chat but the chickpea yeah it was
nice it was so i
do you know what generally when i have
it i don't like it yeah you don't like
that i know
generally when i have it i don't like it
but this time i had it today
and i actually enjoyed it it actually
tastes really good
the lamp how did you find that
not comparing it with the lampara
because it too i'm just saying it's bad
i didn't say it was bad
i'm saying that i i i'm saying that i
like it yeah it was flavorsome
yeah but for me it was lacking sign
anything else
dessert i like asian desserts um
the main thing i really like is the
carrot thing we didn't have it today but
even when it had the care and the
rashmani i still enjoyed it yeah would i
come here again and have this again
that's how i would
yeah bring it out or five stars yeah
probably give it a 4.5
because not only that i don't know the
whole food that's what i'm talking about
four four you give what four point five
no no no point fives no 4 or 5.
that has my feelings i'll give it a four
then
four okay how about you um
i'll give the food three out of five the
reason for that is okay
i'm not being too critical yet yeah but
i'm just thinking about um
the starter the fish was banging yeah
love the fish the flavor was
fine yeah uh the chart a complete
opposite to what he said
um yeah because you're building layers
and layers and layers of
of flavors yeah yeah and it was bland
all right the meat was black okay okay
the chocolate i put in there
because i had the whole thing i had the
chard of the puri
the sauce everything i was trying to
have everything together i built layers
of
how you're supposed to eat it yeah and
when i had it together as was how you
supposed to eat it it was kind of bland
when it came to the main course
uh the peshwari lamb banging
yeah yeah i like that i really enjoyed
that it was really nice
the chilli the ginger the freshness of
the ginger blah blah blah that was
really good
uh the lamb brain yeah the brain itself
and the food the texture was was really
really nice yeah
however when i'm thinking of a curry and
masala i'm looking for depth for flavors
right i'm looking for that to bring me
back to that like you said that
traditional thinking yeah right
because it's like you said it's not like
everywhere you can get lamb brain
yeah so if you are going to do a lamb
brain you have to do it traditionally
and give me that depth of flavors
okay which was lacking okay so you said
free
you said four yep now i'm going to bring
my taking on yeah because i wanted to
hear from you guys so you know
no they're going to influence us okay
me personally like the fish the fish was
banging
the charts try to put it in that's
madness
uh it's the first time i tried usually i
don't like to take risks when i when i'm
having food while my sister so
i tried the peshawari thing yeah like
you said before the lamb karate
the the lam karai usually you had it
yeah no i haven't had it here you
haven't no idea
yeah so that's why but if i were to have
something else inside
it would be that 100 yeah because it's
very similar and it's very nice yeah i
would personally i would
because we don't have hearts i would i
would say
four as well i would say definitely four
yeah
that's the food how was the service so
for example
when we came here yeah the way they
dealt with us
um it was busy like i said the service
was very good the people was very
friendly
uh they accommodated our needs and
requirements and everything
although they are busy and we've got
people waiting and everything yeah
they are accommodating all the only
thing i have to say is about my water
that's it that's the only thing i don't
know from that but that's the stuff
that's a minute thing
yeah which i would think is it's not
good
okay what would you give it out of five
i would say five out of five they've
been very
yeah brilliant in terms of service so
it's a brilliant man
yeah yeah i think you'll go on point
okay i'm gonna base it upon
me coming here before yeah and me coming
here before
yeah yeah the service it was good i
can't there's nothing i'm complaining
about yeah they will take you there
when you come there they'll bring it to
your table yeah
i'll definitely i'll say five stars no
problem how was the time
the time i was happy
yes so bearing that in mind in a normal
restaurant usually food takes around 35
to 40 minutes
that's like your jani standard freestyle
two two-star to us yeah
this was quite yeah so i'm bearing in
mind it's busy because if it's not busy
and it comes fast
it don't mean nothing because you're not
busy anyway so bearing in mind is busy
when the mind time comes what would you
give it out five stars
you can't afford the time you can't
fault the time
yeah you can't afford the time what
would you give about five i'll give you
five yeah
it was fine eight minutes i got my food
within that eight minutes i was just
talking before i know the food was here
it's not the bigger the portion the
bigger the stars if it's too much will
drop starts because the waste
waste of food so bearing that in mind
how was the push of your starter
how was the portion the portion of the
star was good for three people
because we had two coming through two
sides yeah two three people yeah i think
that was a good that was a good amount
we had
yeah so for portion three or four star
three or four so that's one confused
three or four
okay i'll go four
i'll go four that's me okay
i'm gonna okay the starters were banging
yeah started was fine
the main meal your if it was just your
brave thing and i liked it yeah i could
probably have that on my own yeah
the best way though that's not the same
old man
i'm confused can one of you guys have to
three or four i said cool
you said free so you choose that's what
you're here for
okay i'll go with four it's reasonable
because
the only reason i'm not giving it five
is because that thing was too much that
was a lot
so that's why okay first off finally the
price
excuse me can we have a menu a menu so
you're brain team
11 11 pound 15 our peshwari
the chicken is 20 pounds the lamb is 25
pounds yeah starters
are around average five pounds thank you
okay so average the starters average
five pounds
yeah we ordered narratives
so so alhamdulillah it doesn't say ah
the peshwari for two people
it doesn't yeah it is a general okay
what would you give out five stocks for
price
that perfect standard is just standard
curry house price i would i would
i wouldn't say it's anything special
okay i know i wouldn't say it's over
over the board i mean that's just what
would you say
i'll go four out of five okay four zero
do you have a dessert menu do you have a
dessert menu
based on this with the desserts very
reasonable prices
two pounds that's very reasonable bro
usually other places three four pounds
when i was twenty two thirty piers two
twenty nine that's that's that's
that's four star straight down bro okay
first time okay good
so that was our quality check so let's
come to the halaunas so these are the
ones the brothers and sisters out there
who are watching are extra righteous
yeah the ones who are getting piety
attacks and they're more concentrated
rather than the food this is the menu
fully hello
yeah one stuff do they serve alcohol
no one stop there's a chick on the back
of the chicken
do they play music no no one stop
do they have privacy for sister
celebration
if they wanted to i don't know they do
upstairs they have like a special
segment but
sometimes available sometimes it's not
but bearing in mind that a lot of
restaurants do not cater for that
and they do have an indicator for what
they can do yes
i'm going to give it a start because
it's hard it's very hard so upstairs
you can request it so that's very good
one star yeah
do they have a prayer room within the
restaurant
no they don't no they don't oh you don't
they have it they have a masjid right
across the road
so you can't judge up on that so no star
that's it this is your opportunity
actually to win a meal for four now how
do you want to do that very simple
throughout the video inshallah we're
gonna ask you a question so what are
those questions going to be
number one in order for you to win the
meal for four easy all you have to do is
the following you have to go to the gift
uh gifthouse page on instagram which
we're gonna put the link below follow
take a screenshot send that to me on
insta if it's possible if it is possible
yeah that's number one yeah okay
or in the comment section yeah number
one that's the first thing
the second thing is giftos is openly a
new restaurant
where are they opening it a turkey
b china c
singapore dubai
you need to find that out by going to
the insta page
number two the brother who took our
order what was his name
question number three we had a number
behind us
what is our table number and
lastly when did giftos open up
if you get those questions right and
follow uh gifto's
instagram and tag four friends on the
instagram post i'm gonna make or in the
comments section
then you're gonna win inshallah we're
gonna choose someone to win
and insha'allah you'll come here with
your family so brother sisters till next
time
from salaam dining assalamu alaikum